freude herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge einen tag persönlicher koch
ich bin hier heute bei smiley was geht
was geht du wirst den ganzen tag von mir
gekocht sehr sehr reiches menü was wir
zusammen gestellt haben wir beginnen den
tag mit dreck fürs burritos habe ich
vorgeschlagen was ich zugeben und new
york ich freue mich richtig drauf um zu
essen zuzubereiten
du kannst sie gemütlich machen kann
nicht einfach deinen taten nachgehen und
ich bin ihr in der küche sind noch mal
entspannt so freunde gebe ganz kurz
unsere zutaten durch die draußen bleiben
dicken decken das ist so spezieller
grill beckmann kann aber auch die
baustrecke nehmen in den würfel hat uns
perfekt totti as natürlich es sind
worauf selbstverständlich hier chips und
für den extra kramp eine große
fleischtomaten avocado mutter die messe
findet okay leute die wollen wir dieses
heftige messern und sich ein auto sind
sehr kraft und dann um jetzt und denken
wir brauchen nämlich am längsten ist ein
sehr schnelles drücken ihr müsst mir
nämlich jetzt auf den weg geben
das sind ja nur fünf dicke scheiben
merken so ein bisschen barbecue gewürz
bräuchten wir jetzt nicht unbedingt aber
es ist find den schneiden wir jetzt so
in eineinhalb zentimeter dicke streifen
wenn ihr die möglichkeit habt dann macht
das ganze auf einem backblech mit
alufolie nachrufen zu ober unterhitze
200 grad
und so lassen wir das ganze jetzt
knusprig während 20 25 minuten mit
unseren kollegen also einer kleinen
feier
dafür brauchen wir eine reife
fleischtomate schneiden oben unten ab
und da dürfen wir das ganze schon so
thoma kommt schon mal in die schüssel
hineinschreiben jetzt eine verabredung
schneiden oben und unten bis hinab haben
sie mit kernen weil das meine ich gerne
scharf mag wenn es nicht so gerne
schaffen
das macht sein wird das kommt also auch
dazu gemüse zwiebel halbieren von hinten
abschneiden und in feine würfel sagte
mir auch alles dazu dann würden wir
jetzt normalerweise ein bisschen
koriander reinmachen mag ihn nicht mag
ich nicht deshalb dass man es einfach
weg die schale und er sagt von einer
limette presse wäre welt aber ich habe
nicht mal selbst hause eine also noch
stehen dann ein ordentlicher schluck
olivenöl pfeffer warum zeigt dann
schmeißt das ganze jetzt ein bisschen
durch und lassen das marinieren werden
wir die restlichen zubereitung macht es
riecht schon holt ra lecker und richtig
schön mexikanisch daneben uns neue
schlüssel schlagen sechs eier hinein ich
freue mich so darauf not glaube das ist
mit eines der frühstücks häufig mit am
meisten gefreut habe selbst zu essen
weil das kriegst du einfach nicht ich
liebe sachen die man nicht kriegt in
deutschland also ich kenne zumindest bei
uns in köln keinen einzigen wahren der
brecht britos macht geil wenn man so
etwas selbst machen kann oder setzen wir
unsere eier ordentlich und verqueren sie
lasst euch von niemandem erzählen dass
ihr eure nicht leisten könnten positiv
erklärt man kann es probleme machen habe
ich nachts herunterlassen dass sich
kultur für fünf bis zehn minuten
jetzt war es schon gar nicht mehr so
viel zu tun übrig viele tiere seien eine
avocado weil wir gleich schöne pokale
filets nach oben drauflegen werden auf
unseren bericht auf der avatare bosch
hat wieder zugeschlagen
hier seht ihr freunde warum es schlau
wäre das ganze auf dem backblech zu
machen
jetzt heißt es öl was wir vorne an der
kante steht aber der weg und sieht sehr
gut aus zeit die herdplatte anzumachen
dazu geben wir den großzügigen stich
butter so 30 gramm
wenn die butter so leichte bläschen wird
gehen wir unser ai dazu
dann stellen wir den herauf mittlere
letzte umfang an das ganze so schön
konstant zu spenden
das ganze soll nicht zu hart nicht zu
weich werden parallel schon meine zweite
pfanne auf den herd dass die 1
darin tauchen wir es gleich unsere
matthias an weil dann ist das schon so
weit ich gehen mit ein bisschen salz und
pfeffer natürlich auch sollte und die
sind ja schon mal gesagt zum bohren
ein bisschen zurück aber wir sind auf
einem guten weg mal die hitze aus direkt
erreicht jetzt auf die wir machen so
kleine süße reckless burritos also für
konsistenz jetzt gut sagt setzt sich
noch als ich nämlich von der letzte
posten wir das ganze einfach nur ein
bisschen anderen machen es waren dann
willst du dich besser bearbeiten lässt
so freunde dann fangen wir auch an in
die mitte kommt guter klecks von unserem
rührei darauf von unserer welt ist ein
bisschen ungleichmäßig geraten ich mache
mir hier ein paar schöne mädchen für
smiley drauf hat auf jeden fall was dass
der nicht so klassisch beten mäßig ist
hier eben ein wenig schöner oben drüber
sind gucken das ist nicht so groß wird
diesen wirklich nicht mehr groß die sich
ja für die textur echt nicht viel und
dann vorsichtig worte er hoffe ich
kriege ich noch zu ein wenig rock a du
darfst nenne ich mal frühstück und dann
heute das ganze so gut zu sagen wir
können 2d das frühstück für skurrile
hast ja wann gibt's ich mir ein auto ich
halte ich für wundert euch nicht da ist
start weg ein jet sondern es nicht der
ist hier
ich hab zwei liga mit dem frühstück war
darunter fortnight unterbrochen aber
lasst uns einfach den ersten bisschen
nehmen ich bin sehr gespannt was zu
sagen ist und ich freue mich sehr auf
die polizei los metro viele sagen wir
sehen uns bald wieder freunde
das war ein frühstück ich bewerte selbst
einfach mal gar nicht weit hat ist man
frühstück sollte kann man auf jeden fall
sagt wir können uns vielleicht auch um
die rechte aber so kann es gerne schon
mal sagen wie ein standard also ich nur
sagen es war somit das bildest du
fürchtet was ich seit langem hatte
deswegen 0 bis 10
stramme acht ok sehr sehr leid sie haben
es auch super lecker wenn ich irgendwo
in mir nur selbst machen es ist schnell
gemacht lecker beim mittagessen gebe ich
noch mehr wm bis dahin kommen wir zum
mittagessen leute einen schönen
traditionellen ceasar salad für mich ich
glaube einer der besten salat und wir
brauchen auf jeden fall viel knoblauch
wir machen dass sie das pressing selbst
und wir machen selbst gemachtes
knoblauchbrot angst oder anstelle von
protox wir brauchen aber so 120 gramm
butter macht das jetzt ein bisschen nach
auge
es ist denkbar einfach was ihr form
heute ihr welt gleich sehen ich habe
eigentlich ein kleines boot trauma ich
musste nämlich gerade in einem video mit
dima in block butter einen weißen habe
ich zwischendurch aufgenommen
wir brauchen die dafür ist miley
aufgenommen das kommt wahrscheinlich
irgendwann die tage jetzt haben wir
schon mal 3 knoblauchzehen das ist sehr
entspannt für mich ein salat zubereiten
weil einfach kein timing hat das ganz
entspannt fertigmachen größere folge
persönlicher kopf nach meinem geschmack
denn auf jeden fall auch schon recht
folgen dabei gewesen durch so sehr an
meine grenzen gekommen bin ich probiert
schon mal wenig zu zeigen im video
das muss reichen das ging mir mit in
unsere schlüssel butter und knoblauch
schon drin und dann braucht man auch ein
bisschen petersilie das nie gestritten
wie ein bisschen ab indem bisschen
zusammen mit der serienfertigung gehen
wir die auch dazu wir haben jetzt ein
wenig parmesan hinein 20 gramm
jetzt bleibt es nur das alles zusammen
zu mischen und wäre eine traumhafte
selbstgemachte knoblauch betrachten dann
brauchen jetzt nur noch einen statt das
machen wir so ein halb zentimeter
oberhalb von der vom boden davon nur die
untere seite oberseite benutzen wir aber
später noch kein sorgt damit das nicht
austrocknet und dann brauchen wir jetzt
unsere kräuterbutter ja es ist extrem
viel aber es soll ja extrem lecker
werden eben wir auch wo wir mal also das
ganze verstreicht jetzt einfach
gleichmäßig auf dem ganzen brot jetzt
nehmen uns ein bisschen backpapier
eintracht und geben unser
weiterhin 1 6 knoblauchzehen die
schnappen wir uns menschen sie und jetzt
werden wir so lange mit unserem messer
über den knoblauch bis eine paste
entsteht so sieht das ganze aus wenn die
zehn minuten alles lebens damit
verwendet habe das ganze so ganz ganz
fein zu hacken ihr könnt es dann einfach
wie einen aufstrich verschmieren bevor
wir damit weitermachen ziehen wir ganz
kurz unser kräuterbeet raus weil schon
gute zehn minuten im ofen in streifen
geschnitten gebe ich noch mal ein
bisschen zum antworten hinein
jetzt benötigen wir noch drei sardellen
man nicht zu laut sagen und ich meine
man keinen fisch aber das kathrein
beziehungsweise den eben nur 2 die
hatten wir auch ganz fein das müssen wir
dann unter so haben unsere passte fertig
und ich bin schon fast ein bisschen
schwitzen wir machen von dem ganzen
schneiden das geben jetzt so hinein in
unsere beschlüsse dazu geben wir zwei
eigelb man den saft von eineinhalb
zitronen und jetzt einen großen
großzügigen test löffel die songs sind
jetzt haben wir jede menge salz dazu und
mädchen alles zusammen
das ist die einzige schnee wie kein
zweiter hat aber damit kann ich arbeiten
alles gut vermengen fügen wir nach und
nach 300 milliliter öl hinzu es ist jede
menge völlig am schwitzen aber wir haben
es geschafft die konsistenz ist sehr
sehr nah ist und jetzt reiben wir sahen
darunter rund 70 gramm ein ganz schönes
40 kite wenn ihr die ganze küche
verwüstet war irgendwann fertig in der
mal in einer salatschüssel wird jetzt
dieser topf dran glauben müssen wir
erreichen den salat in mundgerechte
stücke romana salat ist das übrigens der
saison
da wird es jetzt zeit unseren salat zu
salzen ganz genau wir werden unsere
salatblätter sei
weil warum nicht die seiten unserer
salatblätter weil alles neuer geschmack
habe auch wenn vielleicht kein pressing
an einem einzigen blatt ist sodann
nehmen jetzt unser dressing und geben
das verteilt über unseren salat rüber
wir werden nicht alles gebraucht und
einfach mit den händen das ganze jetzt
ein bisschen durch werfen wenn mich auch
jedes land ordentlich und dann so schön
dressing abbekommt das konnten wir dann
noch mit unseren kurs und fertig
[Musik]
der smiley es ist endlich soweit kicker
was die stadt das täterbild aus dann
geschieht ein zitat von null auf sechs
so kann man selbst macht das ist die
besonderheit die habs gerade gesehen und
ich bin echt ins schwitzen gekommen man
musste sehr viel schneiden sehr viel
hören ich hoffe es hat sich gelohnt
lasst uns gerne mal probieren fall schon
sehr gut aus doch hatte ich gedacht dass
mein ding rein oder anders das war für
mich wirklich mit zehn von zehn straits
airport zrt ohne irgendwelche weiteres
selbst gebracht wurde ich liebe brot was
innen wie außen plus bringen ist was
mich wirklich also einfach das geilste
verbrauch paket ist auch schon für mich
verriet dass selbst gemacht noch mal
geil dann die frösche salatblätter mit
den franzosen streiten drauf und die
soße dazu alle wünsche erfüllt das war
eine bewertung nach meinem geschmack
leute einfach konnten in die fresse ich
muss auch sagen dass war ultra lag
arbeit hat sich gelohnt ihr habt gesehen
eine kleine sache nicht nur vorstellen
könnte das hat man jetzt gar nicht mehr
gemerkt am ende weil so viel abhängen
auf den teller aber man könnte statt
olivenöl nur so raffel pflanzen müssen
weil ich glaube dass nimmt so ein
bisschen von seiner schärfe bitterkeit
weg aber dass sich auf höchsten niveau
ich find auch das war jetzt lecker und
jetzt kommen zu einem ganz entspannten
abend essen käse lauchsuppe ist das
stichwort viele menschen lieben sie ich
selbst habe ich glaube ich noch gar
nicht so super oft gegessen habe aber
ein gutes rezept thomas koch gefunden
wie der name sagt es ist eine laufgruppe
die menschen brauchen wir auch zum glück
habe ich hier welchen zwei stangen dann
schneiden wir der länge nach auf glatt
schon ein bisschen erde denn hier habe
ich raus gewaschen dann natürlich nicht
mit in der suppe haben das schneiden
jetzt einfach schön dass auch so ein
klassisches oma essen oder was würdet
ihr sagen wo man merkt richtig dass auch
zwiebel ist also die augen sind auch
schon fast ein bisschen an trennen wir
hätten das
schon mal ein top heiß werden schnell
weiter mit den kartoffeln bis auf zwei
werde ich alle würfel wo ich ein recht
einfaches rezept lauchsuppe meinte keese
lauchsuppe das wäre sogar kriegen oder
der tochter in wird jetzt heißt es sehr
guter braten wir nämlich gleich
rinderhack fleisch dran und damit das
schöne farbe bekommt und röstaromen
abgelöst hatte wo ich nicht nicht
knallig heiß werden sondern fertig
gewürfelt und die anderen beiden reihen
werden wird es richtig heiß und wir
geben unser so muss das auch sinn
und wenn das alles angebraten jetzt
kommt der lauch obendrauf verkehr drüber
so wenn der lauf schon eingefallen ist
ihr seht dass hier wird es auch zeit
dass wir gemüsebrühe drauf geben und
zwar einen liter und dann kommen auch
unsere kartoffeln rein und zwar
gleichzeitig die geriebenen und die
gewürfelten die geriebenen sind gerieben
damit sie quasi sich so auflösen in der
suppe und die anderen gegebenheit bis
struktur so das ganze ist schön
eingekocht und wir geben einen guten
schluck sahne dazu diese liegt erst so
diese typische farbe dazu aber freuen
ihr erinnert euch unser roth vom
mittagessen nicht vergessen ist es hier
saftig geblieben dadurch dass ich das so
aufeinander gelegt habt geht jetzt
einfach ein bisschen olivenöl über
unsere brot- und so gehen wir das jetzt
film paar minuten zum am besten auf die
post so fand ich habe jetzt hier im blog
käse der sich nicht so gut verbrechen
lässt aber wir werden ihnen auch in
lange streifen reiben
davon gehen wir dann ein paar in die
suppe hinein ein paar oben auf die super
drauf wird auf jeden fall längere
angelegenheit
[Musik]
smiley sicher das große finale
die königsdisziplin ist vermissen wir
wollen wird ein trauriger tag wir haben
eine neue schicht drauf zieht auf jeden
fall sehr sehr das ist sieht dort hat
die beauty shop sind stevens schöne
aussicht es ist halt hausmannskost
sondern das bleibt einfach ist es mein
lieblingsessen
ja ich bin schon sehr guten hey leute
mit qualitativ ja wo ich jetzt bin ich
auch richtig folge ist ein komplett voll
aber wo sahne käse kartoffeln macht auf
jeden fall sagt also wie gesagt ich
werde es vermissen
htc hat gründe abschluss war angeklagt
war richtig gut war eine geschmacklich
auf jeden fall der 10
also war also der salat hat mir sogar
ein bisschen besser geschmeckt weil der
sofres war okay ja eher als ich meinen
deswegen würde ich hier sagen denn 96
fährt trotzdem halt mein
lieblingsgericht ich bin voll in tritt
und nicht ganz erfüllt geil da freue ich
mich leute was für ein meister tat das
hat nicht wirklich vergleichsweise
entspannt habe ich ja schon mal gesagt
trotzdem übel ist lecker ich vernommen
alles supergut macht gerne nach denn es
für mich einfach macht ich habe das auch
und wir sehen uns beim nächsten video
wieder